[Applaudissements]
chers amis
quel immense joie d'être ici ce soir
avec vous quel immense joie mais quel
immense défi aussi ce soir je parle chez
toi laurent et en plus ce soir je dois
parler après toi et c'est très difficile
de te succéder à la tribune
tous les soirs je t'ai vu sur scène tant
de fois au cours des dernières semaines
et tant de fois je me suis dit j'ai
tellement de progrès à faire et je
voudrais te dire cher laurent à quel
point au cours de cette campagne j'ai
été heureux puisque effectivement c'est
ce soir le dernier meeting que nous
partageons ensemble dans cette campagne
de l'élection européenne à quel point
j'ai été heureux de mener cette campagne
avec toi à quel point je te suis
reconnaissant de ce choix que tu as fait
de la confiance que tu m'a accordé des
policiers exceptionnel que tu m'as
offert pour pouvoir mener ensemble cette
campagne et cette aventure à quel point
je voudrais te dire que je suis sûr dans
quelques jours nous serons à la hauteur
de ce pari qu'à travers toi notre
famille politique a fait
et que de chemin parcouru
que de chemin parcouru au cours des
dernières semaines que de route entre
lyon et lyon cher laurent tous les
chemins parts de lyon et tous les
chemins il ramène c'était ni mars et mi
mars nous étions déjà ici dans cette
région dans cette région d'où tout est
parti
et de nous sommes de nous nous sommes
lancés sur les routes de france nous
avons fait tant de distance de
pont-à-mousson à toulouse de nice
jusqu'à calais et nous sommes revenus
ici ce soir au terme de ce long parcours
ce parcours nous l'avons fait ensemble
ce parcours je crois qu'il a été fort
parce qu'il a été l'occasion d'avancer
rassembler et je voudrais te dire merci
chers hervé merci de ta confiance merci
de ton soutien merci de ta présence de
tes conseils
merci de ton amitié je sais que le 27
mai tu ne me refera pas le coup de
l'étoile ville et j'espère qu'on pourra
partager encore bien des conversations
faire ensemble bien du chemin parce
qu'en effet ce que vous disiez tous les
deux est vrai et c'est la grande leçon
de cette campagne que nous avons mené ce
n'est que dans l'unité qu'on peut
avancer efficace qu'on peut avancer
confiant et qu'on peut avancer heureux
et c'est cette leçon qu'il nous faudra
garder au cours des semaines qui
viendront et puis je voudrais remercier
de tout coeur ceux qui ont fait ce
chemin avec nous partout en france
ceux qui ont fait la force de cette
campagne cette campagne n'a pas été
porté par une tête de liste elle a été
portée par une liste ce soir je voudrais
avoir un mot particulier pour l'une des
grandes figures de cette liste c'est la
première fois c'est le premier meeting
la première réunion publique qu'il y a
sur cette liste
celui qui a le grand honneur d'être le
premier mais qui a surtout le grand
honneur d'être suivi par un si grand
dernier le dernier de notre liste michel
d'antan
michel michel dantin incarne ce que un
parlementaire européen peut représenter
de plus sérieux de plus constant le plus
efficace aussi pour défendre la voix de
la france pour défendre en particulier
notre agriculture qui est un pan si
essentiel de cette culture que nous
voulons préserver et michel haut depuis
le début de cette campagne n'a cessé de
me prodiguer ses conseils ses
enseignements de m'apprendre ce qu'il
fallait pour être le plus efficace et à
travers lui au fond c'est toute cette
équipe incroyable arnaud danjean agnès
even que je voudrais remercier parce que
je n'ai été que le porte-voix de tout le
travail qu'il faisait pour pouvoir
défendre le plus dignement possible nos
idées notre vision le cap que nous
voulons proposer pour l'europe que nous
voulons
je voudrais remercier bien sûr ce que
vous avez vu sur cette scène commerce et
stéphanie remercie antoine remercier
gaëtan sandrine gérald nathalie bernard
remercier philippe meunier bien sûr pour
sa présence sa confiance son soutien
pour la force de son propos et la
fidélité qu'il tient je voudrais
remercier évidemment sonia qui est venu
nous porter le message de l'outre-mer et
te dire sonia que tu peux répondre à
tout ce que tu représentes que nous
viendrons en outre-mer évidemment
c'était la grande frustration c'était
peut-être le seul grand défaut la seule
grande tristesse de cette campagne que
nous n'ayons pas pu venir dans une
campagne si dense et si intense mais ce
n'est que partie remise et le rendez
vous est pour bientôt
nous viendrons chère sonia c'est sûr et
puis je voudrais enfin remercier ceux
qui ont fait la force de cette campagne
diran immense merci puisque c'est notre
dernier meeting ensemble à ceux qui ont
permis de porter cette campagne que nous
avons partagés l'un des colistiers pas
des moindres celui qui a assuré la
fonction difficile de directeur de
campagne je crois qu'on peut tous
applaudir ensemble geoffroy didier
remercié à travers lui aussi et avec lui
et c'est un peu inhabituel mais je
voudrais le faire ce soir je voudrais
qu'on le fasse tous ensemble parce
qu'ils sont les chevilles ouvrières
qu'on ne voit pas qu'on entend pas mais
qui font tout le travail je voudrais
remercier toute l'équipe de campagne qui
a travaillé au cours des dernières
semaines et qui s'est donné sans compter
et puis je voudrais dire un immense
merci à tous ceux qui sont ici ce soir
encore ils auront été de tous les rendez
vous et il en fait je crois vraiment la
force du travail que nous avons porté
ensemble
il est beau d'être une famille politique
qui n'est pas né d'hier il est beau
d'être une famille politique qui sait
compter sur cet enracinement cultiver
patiemment au service des français
partout dans les territoires
il est beau d'une d'être une famille
politique qui sait compter sur la
générosité de ces élus qui partout
représente ceux qui font tenir notre
démocratie aujourd'hui ceux qui font que
la france tient encore ces élus locaux
ces élus de terrain ces élus engagés au
service des citoyens qui part tout
réparé le tissu social abîmé
entretiennent ce qui a été déchiré
rapproche ceux qui se sont éloignés
je voudrais que nous remercions ensemble
nos mères nos conseillers municipaux
nos conseillers départementaux de
conseillers régionaux
et puis ce qui bien sûr portes
aujourd'hui et notre liberté dans une
vie démocratique parfois si asphyxiés ce
qui à temps et à contretemps sont restés
fidèles ceux qui n'ont pas lâché ce
qu'ils n'ont pas abandonné et ceux qui
se font le porte-parole de cette
démocratie encore vivante
je voudrais que nous puissions dire un
immense merci ils sont nombreux ce soir
à tous nos parlementaires à tous nos
députés tous nos sénateurs qui font la
voix de notre pays dans sa diversité
aujourd'hui et je le dis ranimer
remercier tout particulier à annie
genevard pour le soutien qu'elle nous
apporte depuis le début de cette
campagne
enfin bien sûr je me tourne vers vous
pour vous dire à vous aussi la
reconnaissance que j'éprouve parce que
c'est vous qui êtes ici ce soir qui fait
notre espoir
vous êtes venus ce soir vous avez fait
la route vous avez pris de votre temps
vous êtes ici dans cette campagne que
tout le monde disait joué d'avancé dans
cette élection que tout le monde disait
perdu d'évidence pour notre famille
politique et le fait que vous soyez là
dit que non rien n'est joué et que dans
les quatre jours qui viennent nous
allons vivre j'en suis sûr en effet les
belles surprises dont nous avons besoin
pour pouvoir servir la france et pouvoir
refonder l'europe
servir la france et refonder l'europe
c'est évidemment ce qui nous anime
depuis le début de cette campagne c'est
la seule chose dont nous parlons c'est
la seule chose qui nous importe
jamais nous n'avons le voulu faire de
cette élection l'occasion du troisième
tour de l'élection présidentielle
jamais nous ne nous serions permis de
détourner cette élection européenne sans
doute l'une des plus importantes depuis
le début de l'histoire du projet
européen
parce que l'europe est à la croisée des
chemins et jamais nous ne nous serions
permis de faire de cette campagne un
référendum pour ou contre la politique
du président de la république bien sûr
que nous nous opposons à la politique du
président de la république mais ce qui
est en jeu aujourd'hui c'est l'europe et
ce président de la république qui nous
avait dit que l'europe était le coeur de
son engagement nous a expliqué ce matin
que la seule question était de voter
pour ou contre lui comme s'il devait
être le seul sujet de la vie
démocratique
quelle incroyable narcissisme nous
voulons parler d'europe
et depuis le début de cette campagne
nous ne parlons que de robes de cette
europe dans laquelle les défiances sont
si grandes de cette europe dans laquelle
la crise est si profonde depuis le début
de cette campagne nous entendons ces
voix de français qui nous disent qu'ils
ont le sentiment que l'europe leur a
manqué que l'europe n'arrive pas à les
renforcer dans la mondialisation
nous croyons évidemment que l'europe est
plus nécessaire que jamais nous croyons
évidemment que pour relever tous les
grands défis de notre avenir
il nous faut agir en europe mais nous
savons aussi bien sûr que pour que
l'europe soit efficace et qu'elle fasse
de nouveau la preuve de son efficacité
pour recréer la confiance il faut
réorienter en profondeur la manière dont
elle agit et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ce débat ne peut pas être
binaire ce débat c'est pas blanc ou noir
c'est pas populiste ou progressistes
c'est pas gentil ou méchant devant ceux
qui doutaient qu'ils s'inquiètent notre
devoir n'est pas de lancer des anathèmes
on ne fera pas reculer la colère en
l'insultant
on ne fera reculer la colère quand lui
apportant des réponses sérieuses en lui
offrant une alternative concrète en lui
proposant un nouvel espoir et voilà ce
que nous nous sommes attachés à faire
passer
- blement tout au long de cette campagne
voilà ce à quoi nous avons consacré tout
notre temps sans discontinuer au contact
des français à l'écouté des français
partout en france tous les jours sur le
terrain parler d'europe et proposer aux
français qui doute et qui s'inquiète aux
français qui nous faisait partager leurs
aspirations et leurs espoirs
une europe qui puisse répondre à ce dont
ils ont besoin pour pouvoir nous
renforcer dans la mondialisation pour
pouvoir nous renforcer face aux défis
économiques et commerciales qui se joue
aujourd'hui autour de nous car oui c'est
vrai nous avons besoin de redonner de
l'oxygène à ceux qui travaillent de
redonner du travail à tous les français
nous avons besoin de retrouver le sens
de notre fierté dans le monde qui se
dessine
nous ne voulons pas être les spectateurs
d'un monde qui se ferait sans nous nous
savons que nous sommes capables d'en
être encore les acteurs nous savons que
nous sommes capables de contribuer à
continuer d'écrire l'histoire de ce
monde qui se dessine
mais pour cela encore faut-il que
l'europe assume de défendre ses
entreprises et ses emplois pour cela
encore faut-il que dans la compétition
mondiale les règles soient les mêmes
pour tous encore faut-il que nous
parvenions à obtenir de ceux qui veulent
échanger avec nous une vraie réciprocité
dans les échanges commerciaux
et cela mes chers amis cela passe par
l'europe
cela passe par le travail de l'union
européenne et la réorientation du
travail de l'union européenne nous
étions ensemble tout à l'heure avec
yannick noah d'air nous étions à la
rencontre d'une entreprise
exceptionnelle qui fait la fierté de
cette région qui s'appelle soltec cette
entreprise vous ne la connaissez pas et
pourtant dans chacune de vos poches sans
doute il y a quelque chose que cette
entreprise a fabriqué ici dans cette
région auvergne rhône-alpes
cette entreprise fabrique le matériau
qui permet de produire des semi
conducteurs qui sont utilisés par
exemple dans la téléphonie mobile mais
aussi dans l'aéronautique est aussi dans
l'automobile et aussi dans toutes les
industries du futur
cette entreprise-là a su devenir un
point de référence au point
qu'aujourd'hui elles échangent avec tous
les grands acteurs de l'industrie de
demain
et bien cette entreprise aujourd'hui et
ceux qui nous ont permis de la rencontre
et nous partager leurs sentiments
cette entreprise est soutenu
par le travail de l'union européenne
mais aujourd'hui elle souffre d'un
problème fondamental qui touche notre
union européenne et qui est notre
incroyable naïveté dans la
mondialisation
cette naïveté qui fait qu'au fond là où
tous les grandes puissances du monde
protègent leur entreprise et développent
des stratégies forte et affirmée
nous n'avons pour tout stratégique une
doctrine de la concurrence nous avons
choisi systématiquement de privilégier
le consommateur d'ouvrir tous nos
marchés d'ouvrir toute la concurrence au
monde entier pour qu'à la fin nous
soyons sûrs que le consommateur
obtiendra le meilleur produit au moindre
coût c'est ce choix de la consommation
par exemple qui nous a fait empêché le
rapprochement de ces deux entreprises
que sont alstom et siemens et qui fait
qu'à la fin pour faire jouer le jeu de
la concurrence et de la compétition nous
nous sommes sans doute aveuglée sur la
réalité de ces géants industriels
auxquels nos entreprises doivent faire
face aujourd'hui c'est géant industriel
qui viennent de chine des etats-unis
ils sont dans des situations de monopole
sur leur territoire de départ ils sont
largement soutenus par leurs pays
respectifs et nous nous imposons à nos
propres entreprises de jouer le jeu
d'une compétition qui ne se fait pas à
armes égales
nous croyons encore une fois que nos
entreprises sont capables de remporter
bien des batailles
encore faut-il qu'elles puissent jouer
un jeu dans lequel les règles soient les
mêmes pour tous encore faut-il que nous
puissions obtenir de nos partenaires
commerciaux une stricte réciprocité
aujourd'hui nos marchés publics
représentent 20% de la valeur créée en
europe 20% du pib
eh bien ces marchés publics sont ouverts
à 95% aux acteurs internationaux
nous sommes les seuls au monde à
pratiquer cette ouverture les marchés
publics américains ne sont ouverts qu'à
30% les marchés publics chinois 0%
comment est il possible qu'une
entreprise chinoise puisse venir prendre
un marché public en france et faire du
profit en france alors que jamais la
meilleure entreprise française ne pourra
prendre un marché public en chine et
faire du profit en chine
voilà ce qu'il faut changer
nous savons que nous sommes capables de
gagner bien des batailles nous sommes
capables de décrocher des coupes du
monde mais la meilleure équipe du monde
si elle rentre sur un terrain qui n'est
pas plat et dans lequel les règles sont
faussés est sûr de perdre à tous les
coups et c'est ce que nous avons
imposées parfois à nos entreprises par
cette naïveté dans laquelle nous avons
persévéré trop longtemps il faut
désormais construire une europe qui
assume de défendre ses intérêts il faut
construire une europe et nous avons
besoin de l'europe pour cela qu'ils
obtiennent de tous ceux qui voudront
échanger avec nous une stricte
réciprocité
il faut que les règles soient les mêmes
pour tous
et ainsi nous pourrons de nouveau pesé
dans la compétition mondiale et ainsi
nous pourrons rééquilibrer la
mondialisation et ainsi nous pourrons
retrouver ses vrais le sens du travail
que nous avons besoin de remettre à
l'honneur dans notre pays
car oui cette mondialisation que nous
avons laissé se construire elle a fait
partir loin de l'europe bien des forces
de travail des capacités de production
nous avons vécu cette mondialisation
comme une espèce de répartition des
tâches à l'échelle internationale comme
si toute la production devait se faire
en asie et qu'en europe on allait faire
des services et des loisirs comme si il
fallait mettre d'un côté les
travailleurs et de l'autre les
consommateurs et bien cette
mondialisation a produit la catastrophe
économique et sociale que nous
connaissons mais elle a t elle a aussi
produit 7 dévitalisation intérieur la
perte du sens du travail
notre pays vit depuis des années en
déficit commercial depuis des années
notre pays consomme plus qu'il ne
produit est derrière ces statistiques il
y a quelque chose qui touche de
l'intérieur une société qui touche de
l'intérieur une civilisation
oui ce qui fait une société c'est aussi
l'oeuvre commune dans laquelle chacun
réalise quelque chose qui vaut pour les
autres ce qui fait la valeur du travail
n'est pas seulement le fait que le
travail par une pénibilité accepté vient
nous permettre de gagner le pouvoir
d'achat que nous pourrons utiliser
lorsque la vraie vie commencera quand le
travail sera fini non ce qui fait la
véritable valeur du travail
c'est que chacun d'entre nous
s'accomplit dans le travail qu'il fait
en mettant ses propres talents au
service de quelque chose de plus grand
que lui et je crois que nous devons
redécouvrir cette valeur du travail
depuis le début de cette campagne nous
entendons partout en france cette double
inquiétude ce double cris parfois de
colère
nous entendons des français qui disent
je travaille et je ne m'en sors pas je
travaille dur et je ne parviens pas à
joindre les deux bouts des commerçants
des artisans des chefs d'entreprises de
tpe pme qui sont souvent les derniers à
se payer parmi leurs salariés et qui
parfois ne se paye pas
de ceux qui comme les entrepreneurs de
ceux qui comme les innovateurs comme les
chercheurs de ceux qui comme les
agriculteurs ont le sentiment d'être ce
qu'ils risquent tous et qui sont sans
cesse contrôlés par des gens qui ne
risque rien et qui ne parviennent pas à
vivre du travail qu'ils font et dont
pourtant ils nous font vivre et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous entendons ce
deuxième crise sans cesse répéter sans
cesse évoqué et qui est comme un
scandale au coeur de notre société et
laurent tu as été le premier à dénoncer
ce scandale depuis le début de cette
campagne nous entendons des
entrepreneurs des commerçants des
artisans qui disent je pourrais me
développer j'ai besoin de me développer
mais je n'ai besoin que d'une seule
chose pour cela de trouver quelqu'un qui
veuille bien travaillé nous sommes dans
un pays touché par le chômage de masse
mais dans un pays qui a perdu le sens du
travail
au point que ceux qui voudraient
recruter n'arrive pas à en trouver des
bras pour les accompagner des talents
pour s'engager retrouver le sens du
travail c et rééquilibrer la
mondialisation et réapprendre à produire
ce que nous consommons réapprendre à
produire ce que nous consommons aussi
pour remédier à ce grand défi qui est
devant nous et qui est le défi de
l'environnement le défi de l'écologie le
défi de l'écologie est un défi majeur
bien sûr et nous avons échangé tout à
l'heure à grenoble avec ces français qui
savent qu'ils sont directement touchés
par cette asphyxie qui menace un monde
dans lequel effectivement les flux
permanent que nous avons suscité sont en
train de raréfier l'oxygène et de le
rendre irrespirable oui nous avons le
souci de la transmission oui on nous
accuse parfois d'être des conservateurs
et bien assumant que nous voulons offrir
à nos enfants ce que nous avons reçu
deux meilleurs une culture une civilité
une civilisation mais aussi bien sûr une
nature un monde qui soit encore
respirable un monde qui soit encore
habitable et bien pour répondre à ce
grand défi il faut précisément faire
preuve d'un peu d'imagination d'un peu
plus d'imagination que ceux qui pensent
que l'écologie est une affaire de
dépenses publiques et que à problèmes
toute solution est toujours de dépenser
de l'argent public et que à grand
problème il faudrait juste apporté une
énorme dépense publique
non madame l'oiseau il ne suffit pas de
promettre qu'on va dépenser 1000
milliards d'euros pour s'acheter une
conscience écologique
la question qui se pose à nous
[Applaudissements]
ah que l'on voit chers amis que la
gauche française n'a pas tout à fait
disparu
non la question qui se pose à nous n'est
pas d'avoir pour objectif une dépense la
question qui se pose à nous car nous
sommes en effet de droite c'est d'avoir
pour objectif une performance une
efficience un résultat et le résultat
que nous voulons obtenir c'est de
retrouver un monde qui soit habitable et
comment y parvenir
sinon précisément en mettant fin à ce
monde devenu un peu fou dans lequel des
produits font plusieurs fois le tour du
monde sans jamais être arrêté dans cette
course que nous avons laissé suscité
aujourd'hui on coupe des chaînes dans
les forêts de france
on envoie ses chaînes en chine pour
devenir du parquet ou du mobilier et on
les ramène en france pour que vous
puissiez les acheter et ensuite
ensuite on va expliquer aux salariés
français qui a besoin de sa voiture pour
faire 5 km pour aller travailler que
c'est lui qui est responsable de la
crise climatique que c'est lui qui
responsables de la crise écologique et
que celui qu'on va taxer d'ailleurs et
bien non nous disons qu'il faut mettre
en place une barrière écologique à
l'entrée du marché commun pour
effectivement faire en sorte que les
règles soient les mêmes pour tous pour
que nous puissions enfin nous interdire
d'importer ce que nous nous interdisons
de produire car lorsque nous acceptons
de produire ce que nous nous interdisons
lorsque nous nous interdisons d'importer
lorsque nous nous autorisons à importer
ce que nous nous interdisons de produire
c'est là qu'on voit qu'on est fatigué
quand même c'est le signe qu'on a perdu
un peu de cette raison qu'ils voudraient
qu'on défende d'abord nos entreprises et
nos emplois
c'est tout le problème ne pas avoir de
papiers et je crois qu'au fond il ya là
quelque chose comme un grand défi comme
un grand défi qui est celui enfin de
réconcilier économie et écologie des
filles que nous avons exploré avec
franck proust avec angélique delahaye
réconcilier économie et écologie défi
qui est celui que notre famille
politique doit pouvoir honorer bien sûr
des filles qui permettra que nous
puissions cessé de fragiliser ce qu'ils
produisent en europe au nom d'une
écologie devenue folle qui obtient
exactement les résultats qu'elle
prétendait éviter et cette phrase là
j'ai réussi
une écologique devenue folle qui
encourage exactement ce qu'elle
prétendait éviter tout en détruisant
notre propre capacité de produire et
c'est cher michel sur le terrain de
l'agriculture que se joue le plus
souvent cette espèce de contradiction
lorsque nous fixons des normes toujours
plus compliqué à nos agriculteurs des
règles toujours plus sophistiquées des
contrôles toujours plus drastique et
qu'ensuite nous ouvrons notre marché à
des produits qui ont été développées
sans respecter aucune de ces normes et
aucune de ces règles comment se fait-il
que l'agneau néo zélandais cultiver sans
respecter aucun des standards imposés à
nos éleveurs arrive dans nos
supermarchés et qu'il coûte moins cher
que l'agneau élevé tout près de chez
vous par nos propres agriculteurs
voilà tout le sens de cette barrière
écologique qui consiste à faire en sorte
qu effectivement nous puissions
retrouver notre capacité de cultiver et
de produire ce que nous voulons
consommer pour pouvoir rééquilibrer la
mondialisation et voilà un grand défi
européen parce que le fait d'imposer ses
règles à ceux qui veulent importer chez
nous ne pourra se faire qu'au niveau
européen
quand vous êtes un marché de quelques
dizaines de millions d'habitants une
grande puissance mondiale peuvent
facilement vous contournez parce qu'elle
peut facilement faire sans vous les
britanniques le découvre aujourd'hui à
leurs dépens est ce qu'il y a quelques
semaines encore se féliciter du bric si
tu devrais peut-être regarder ce qui
arrive aujourd'hui aux ambitions de nos
amis anglais il croyait pouvoir
commercer avec le reste du monde
il croyait avoir retrouvé la souplesse
qui leur permettrait de passer des
accords avec le reste du monde
aujourd'hui ils découvrent que même avec
les états unis ils sont en position de
faiblesse
parce que les états unis leur dise nous
pouvons échanger avec vous mais nous
pouvons aussi faire sans vous et donc si
vous voulez commercer avec nous ça se
fera selon nos règles
nos standards avec nos exigences et vous
serez contraint d'importer les produits
que nous développons selon nos règles
selon nos standards et selon nos
exigences quand vous êtes un marché de
quelques dizaines de millions
d'habitants
vous êtes contraints de subir ces
grandes puissances et la règle qu'il
vous impose mais personne ne peut faire
sans un marché de 500 millions
d'habitants aucune grande puissance du
monde ne peut faire sans l'europe
le marché commun que nous avons
construit ce marché commun est
aujourd'hui bien trop souvent une cible
facile mais ce marché commun que nous
avons construit peut devenir le levier
exceptionnel qui pourra nous renforcer
dans la mondialisation qui pourra faire
que nos entreprises pèseront dans le
monde qui se dessine qui pourra faire
que nos agriculteurs retrouveront leur
capacité de rayonner dans le monde
entier d'apporter le meilleur de leur
savoir faire à tous les pays du monde
sans subir cette concurrence déloyale
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui en train de
vivre
oui nous devons faire de ce marché
commun un outil politique
oui nous devons construire une europe
qui assume enfin de défendre nos
entreprises et nos emplois
oui nous devons faire une europe qui
sache écrire une règle de préférence
européenne pour faire en sorte qu en
effet nous puissions aujourd'hui ne pas
seulement favorisé le consommateur mais
toujours en même temps regarder que nous
sommes des travailleurs et que nous
voulons rester des travailleurs parce
que c'est par là que notre civilisation
s'est édifié et que c'est par là qu'elle
pourra se transmettre et survivre dans
le monde de demain
rééquilibrer la mondialisation c'est
aussi bien sûr tenter d'apporter une
réponse aux grands défis migratoires qui
est devant nous devant nous et non pas
derrière nous hier encore sur un plateau
de télévision avec lequel nous
partageons un débat hier encore on nous
faisait cette objection mais voyons
s'est terminée la crise migratoire
c'était en 2015 c'est fini et bien non
nous le disons avec la plus grande
clarté la crise migratoire n'a pas
encore commencé elle n'a pas encore
commencé parce que le défi de la
démographie en afrique ce défi est
devant nous et oui laurent tu nous l'a
dit ce défi il faut le prendre à bras le
corps la première des générosités
c'est de maîtriser nos frontières pour
pouvoir accueillir vraiment ceux qui ont
besoin de notre solidarité
mais pour pouvoir ouvrir la porte à
celui qui a besoin de notre solidarité
encore faut-il avoir une porte à lui
ouvrir encore faut-il avoir une demeure
qui soient préservés encore faut-il
avoir un foyer où accueillir oui nous
voulons bien accueillir ceux qui nous
demande d'entrée et qui ont légitimement
besoin de notre aide
mais nous ne voulons pas subir nous
voulons bien ouvrir la porte mais nous
ne voulons pas voir notre porte enfoncée
tous les jours et voilà le défi qui est
devant nous et ce défi chers amis son
ampleur est telle qu'il faut le prendre
en charge en europe avec nos alliés
européens
nous ne sommes pas de ceux qui comme le
rassemblement national
par pure idéologie vote contre l'europe
même quand elle peut servir nos pays
nous ne sommes pas de ce cher philippe
qui par pur dogmatisme crois qu'il
faudrait parier sur l'affaiblissement de
l'europe pour retrouver notre
souveraineté
nous croyons que notre souveraineté que
la maîtrise de notre politique
migratoire
elle peut être appuyé par un vrai
travail européen qu'il faut renforcer
par une vraie stratégie européenne qu'il
faut développer pour que plus jamais on
ne puisse s'établir en europe
si on n'y a pas été légalement autorisés
et oui nous voulons
et oui nous voulons garder cette
souveraineté
nous ne croyons pas une seule seconde à
une europe qui viendrait nous déposséder
de nos choix démocratique
nous ne croyons pas une seule seconde à
cette europe de monsieur macron qui se
contente de gérer l'impuissance qui se
contente de faire en sorte de constater
que les flux migratoires existe qui
explique comme le disait madame
belloubet récemment que l'immigration
on ne l'arrête pas et que de toute façon
elle fait partie de l'histoire si bien
sur l'immigration elle peut elle doit
elle elle suppose même que nous
puissions mettre en oeuvre tous les
moyens nécessaires pour maîtriser
vraiment nos frontières car c'est le
premier acte démocratique
nous voulons pouvoir dire qu'ils nous
pouvons accueillir et nous voulons que
nos élus que ne représentant que nos
parlementaires puisse dire selon nos
capacités d'accueil et d'intégration qui
nous pouvons accueillir
nous ne croyons pas à cette europe de
monsieur macron qui voudraient imposer
des quotas de migrants aux états
européens et les exclure de l'union
européenne s'ils n'acceptent pas de
prendre sur leur sol des quotas
d'immigration
cette europe qui viendra à construire
une double frontières pour pouvoir faire
en sorte que nous puissions à la fois
défendre ensemble les frontières
extérieures de l'europe et garder la
pleine maîtrise de notre politique
migratoire
nous sommes les seuls à la défendre dans
ce débat européen
et s'il nous faut maîtriser les flux
migratoires c'est aussi cher ami parce
que nous avons devant nous un grand défi
à relever un immense défi qu'il nous
appartient de prendre en charge ce défi
c'est celui de préserver l'unité même
d'une société profondément mise en
danger
mise en danger par les communautarismes
qui monte cher stéphanie dont tu as
parlé tant de jeunes qui grandissent en
france aujourd'hui ne se reconnaissent
pas français tant de jeunes qui
grandissent dans notre pays ne se
reconnaissent pas enfants de notre pays
héritier de notre culture et d'une
civilisation commune et c'est vrai que
dans ce débat
il nous a paru nécessaire de placer au
premier plan cette question fondamentale
voulons-nous oui ou non que l'europe
redécouvre ce qu'elle est l'europe n'est
pas une administration l'europe ce ne
sont pas des traités l'europe ce n'est
pas un projet l'europe c'est une
civilisation
il faut redire qui nous sommes hier sur
ce même plateau de télévision
l'un des candidats auxquels nous faisons
face a expliqué très froidement que
s'inquiéter de cette civilisation que se
préoccuper de la définir de la nommer de
nouveaux que tenter de connaître nos
racines notre histoire était j'ai le
site débile eh bien non et c'est avec
cette inconséquence dangereuse que nous
avons laissé se fracturer la société
dans laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui
c'est en ne sachant pas dire qui nous
sommes que nous avons vu se défaire
petit à petit le lien qui nous réunit
bien sûr il nous faut lutter contre
toutes les forces qui tentent de dresser
les français les uns contre les autres
bien sûr il nous faut lutter contre
l'islam radical il nous faut d'abord
nommé l'islam radical qui dans beaucoup
de nos quartiers cherche à construire
les fossés dans lesquelles se
construisent la haine et la guerre de
demain
oui nous croyons que l'europe c'est la
paix et oui nous croyons que si l'europe
c'est la paix il faut préserver cette
paix en luttant contre tout ce qui
menace de faire réapparaître
partout la guerre aujourd'hui nous
n'allons pas rentrer de nouveau en
conflit avec l'allemagne
heureusement nous le devons à nos aînés
qui ont fait cette réconciliation
miraculeuse dont nous avons hérité mais
la guerre peut leur paraître sous
d'autres formes
et lorsque les innocents sont tués à la
terrasse des cafés ou dans des salles de
concert lorsque certains doivent
aujourd'hui en france vivre leur culte
sous protection militaire parce qu'ils
sont de confession juive
plusieurs décennies après la chute du
nazisme alors oui nous pouvons le dire
la guerre peut réapparaître sous
d'autres formes elle réapparaît et nous
devons à ceux qui ont fait la paix dont
nous sommes aujourd'hui héritiers nous
leur devons d'être à la hauteur de cette
réconciliation enfin obtenu après des
siècles de guerre en luttant avec
énergie contre tout ce qui menace de
faire réapparaître la violence et la
barbarie
oui cher laurent tu l'as dit nous devons
lutter de manière impeccable contre
l'islam radical
mais cette grande bataille
elle ne sera gagné à la fin malgré tous
les moyens sécuritaires policiers
judiciaires qu'il nous faut évidemment
mettre en place cette grande bataille
elle ne sera gagné que si nous parvenons
à remplir notre devoir
sur le terrain fondamentale prioritaires
primordial c'est la bataille de
l'éducation c'est la bataille des
esprits
c'est la bataille des coeurs
et oui c'est pour cette raison là qu'il
faut redire qu'il nous sommes c'est pour
cette raison là qu'il faut dire que
l'europe est une civilisation
il faut à tous les jeunes qui
grandissent en france aujourd'hui il
faut donner quelque chose à aimer il
faut leur donner la france a aimé il
faut leur donner l'europe en héritage il
faut le redire qui nous sommes les
enfants de 25 siècles d'histoire de ce
petit miracle de la grèce antique qui
voit naître la raison lorsque les hommes
décident cinq siècles avant jésus-christ
qu'il ne leur suffira plus d'expliquer
le monde par des mythologies mais qu'ils
veulent désormais faire l'effort de la
logique de la pensée rationnelle et
lorsque le logo ce qui n'est devient
dialogos qu'il devient dialogue qu'il
devient délibération délibération par
laquelle nous pouvons entrer en
discussion les uns avec les autres pour
faire de nos désaccords l'occasion d'une
conversation plutôt que de la violence
et lorsque je les ai souvent dit mais il
faut toucher du doigt ce que
concrètement nous devons à cette
histoire magnifique lorsque dans
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée nationale ou
du sénat comme dans le plus modeste
conseil municipal lorsque nous
délibérons pour choisir ensemble notre
avenir nous sommes les enfants des grecs
nous sommes les enfants des romains qui
ont marqué bien sûr cette ville comme
comme aucune autre et d'où est partie
ici cet enseignement magnifique qui veut
qu'il n'y a pas de liberté sans une
respublica sens le sens de la république
le sens de la chose de tous le sens de
l'autorité de l'état
oui lorsque nous nous révoltons de voir
nos centres villes dévastées pendant des
semaines par l'impuissance publique
nous reconnaissons qu'il n'y a pas de
liberté s'il n'y a pas d'ordre public et
en cela nous sommes les enfants des
romains et oui bien sûr et pourquoi ne
pas le dire et pourquoi
et pourquoi avoir tant tardé à le dire
il y a bien sûr au coeur de notre
civilisation
ce que nous devons à cet héritage
magnifique quelle idée à quel héritage
de la tradition chrétienne qui a fait de
nous ce que nous sommes de cette
civilisation judéo chrétienne qui a
porté dans le monde le sens de la
dignité humaine
et oui c'est par là que nous avons
effectivement que dans toute société il
y à un marché mais qu'à la fin cette
ville qui se construit autour d'un
marché depuis le monde grec et le monde
romain
elle doit aussi prendre en charge le
fait que l'homme n'est pas qu'un
consommateur le fait que l'homme n'est
pas qu'un individu qui poursuit ses
propres calculs qu'une société n'est pas
qu'une addition d'individus séparés par
leurs ambitions respectives mais qu'il y
a dans toute personne humaine quelque
chose qui ne se calcule pas quelque
chose qui ne se marchande pas une
aspiration qu'on ne fait pas taire
seulement par les choses matérielles
voilà ce qui fait le balancement
magnifique de cette civilisation
voilà ce qui fait qu'au coeur de lion il
y à la colline qui travaille et la
colline qui prie
voilà ce qui fait qu'au fond nous sommes
les porteurs du sens de ce qu'est
l'humain
nous ne sommes pas que des consommateurs
et bien sûr notre vie est faite aussi de
cette activité économique mais l'oeil
cos à la fin l'économie elle est faite
pour servir en où l'humain et la
prospérité est la condition pour
construire une société plus juste une
société plus humaine
une société où les hommes se sentent
liés par une civilité commune voilà ce
qui fait le message d'une civilisation
et de la civilisation européenne
au coeur du monde d'hier et de demain
alors chers amis pour ce dernier grand
meeting de campagne
je voudrais terminer en partageant avec
vous trois grands espoirs nous avons
beaucoup parlé de nos craintes de nos
doutes et de nos inquiétudes mais nous
avons surtout vécu un élan
extraordinaire au cours de cette
campagne que nous avons partagé ensemble
et oui nous sommes sans doute à la
veille d'un moment important d'un point
de bifurcation décisive pour l'histoire
d'un continent l'histoire d'une
civilisation
nous avons parfois de vraies raisons
d'être inquiet et il faut pouvoir ne pas
céder à un optimisme facile mais nous
avons deux grandes raisons d'espérer et
l'espérance n'a rien à voir avec
l'optimisme
comme le disait georges bernanos
l'optimisme c'est la fuite en avant de
celui qui croit que par définition
l'avenir sera meilleur que le passé de
celui qui pense que par définition le
nouveau monde est meilleur que l'ancien
l'espérance c'est le travail que fait
celui qui croit que la victoire est
possible et qu'il faut y travailler
l'espérance c'est le travail de celui
qui voit toutes les difficultés mais qui
veut aller au bout de la nuit pour
trouver une autre aurore et voilà ce que
nous partageons ensemble nous voyons
bien la crise dans laquelle notre pays
est enlisé
nous voyons bien la crise qui traverse
notre pays mais nous avons vu partout
aussi en france partout toutes ces
raisons d'espérer que nous partageons
aujourd'hui elle ne suppose pas de
sombrer dans le déni de réalité elle ne
suppose pas de s'abandonner à une fuite
en avant absurde
au contraire elle suppose de s'engager
elle suppose d'agir vraiment l'optimisme
du bernanos et de fait il faudrait
qu'ils soient massivement pratiqué dans
la france d'aujourd'hui
l'optimisme c'est par excellence la
vertu du contribuable quand le fils que
la dépouiller de tout même de sa chemise
le contribuable optimiste à beaune à une
revue nudistes et déclare qu'il ne s'est
jamais mieux portée et l'espérance
l'espérance n'a rien à voir avec cela
l'espérance est un combat l'espérance se
conquiert elle nous avons toutes les
raisons d'aller conquérir cette
espérance dont nous avons tellement
besoin toutes les raisons de croire en
la france
je voudrais vous lire quelques mots ce
soir je les ai déjà partagé chez toi
cher gilles à chalon de manière un peu
improvisée et je me suis dit qu'au fond
il était sans doute la meilleure
expression de cette espérance que nous
voulons partager quelques mots que j'ai
reçues il y a quelques années de cela en
je venais de publier un petit livre sur
cette crise de l'éducation cette crise
de la transmission qui est au coeur
aussi du débat que nous partageons ce
petit livre les déshérités m'avait valu
de recevoir ce message que je voudrais
partager avec vous ce message d'un jeune
malien récemment arrivés en france
né en 1992 il avait 23 ans au moment où
ils m'écrivaient je m'appelle la dgi en
france depuis trois ans est élevé dans
l'admiration de la france d'une certaine
idée de la culture française
d'où mon immense gratitude heures et ce
message s'appelait une certaine idée de
la gratitude
j'ai connu la france par les livres par
un professeur de français qui nous
faisait lire la fontaine baudelaire et
balzac
bien sûr je ne vivais pas sous louis xiv
ni dans le paris du 19ème siècle
cet éloignement pourtant ce grand voyage
que notre professeur nous offrait nous
plongeait dans un bonheur extatique
il nous transmettait nous faisait sentir
des choses si élevé si éloigné de notre
quotidien
à ce titre je me considère me dit ce
jeune malien récemment arrivés en france
à ce titre je me considère comme un
héritier de la culture française
héritage au sens que lui donnait charles
péguy d'où qu'on vienne
on avait accès à cet héritage à
vingt-cinq siècles d'histoire au mélange
subtil de homer et de la bible
je suis étonné en arrivant en france de
voir la grande défiance de certains à
l'égard de cet héritage qui était vu
comme encombrants et anachronique votre
livre m'a réconforté par bon ça c'est la
page de publicité grâce à vous je
pourrais dire comme sartre que je suis
français par la langue la transmission
de cet héritage dont j'ai bénéficié
devrait être l'urgence absolue bien
devant toutes les préoccupations
passagère que ne fut pas mon grand
étonnement d'entendre arrivée en france
de jeunes gens qui étaient nés en france
et qui me reprochait de faire mon
français alors que je ne le suis pas mon
professeur de français croyaient qu en
nous faisant lire le cid
on ne régnait pas ce que nous sommes
mais qu on goûtait à ce que l'humanité
avait produit de meilleur on apprenait
ce que la france est avant tout un pays
littéraire qui a nourri avec sa culture
un rapport charnel la culture française
noé commune et la transmission du savoir
est le devoir de toute civilisation
cette lettre d'un jeune homme de 23 ans
[Applaudissements]
a dit tout notre espoir oui nous avons
toutes les raisons d'être confiants dans
notre avenir si nous savons retrouver
nos racines
oui nous avons toutes les raisons d'être
confiants dans notre capacité d'écrire
encore notre histoire si nous savons
nous appuyer sur la force que nous
recevons de ceux qui nous ont précédés
oui il nous faut redécouvrir la
nécessité d'assumer sereinement
paisiblement avec gratitude et
reconnaissance sans orgueil inapproprié
car nous ne sommes pas les auteurs mais
avec le sens de l'obligation qu'elles
constituent pour chacun d'entre nous
nous avons le devoir d'assumer ce qui
nous relie ce qui nous dépasse ce qui
fait la force de nos racines
d'où pourra passer la sève qui nous
projettera vers l'avenir
oui nous avons toutes les raisons
d'espérer chers amis toutes les raisons
d'espérer
[Applaudissements]
et ma deuxième raison d'espérer elle est
dans la crise que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être paradoxal
mais dans cette crise nous voyons bien
que nous sommes un point de bifurcation
que nous sommes à la croisée des chemins
que nous sommes à l'heure des grandes
décisions
et bien c'est le moment d'agir pour
refonder l'europe et c'est le moment
d'agir pour rétablir la france et c'est
le moment de saisir cette occasion qui
nous est offerte cette occasion
historique de prendre conscience des
erreurs du passé pour ne pas les
recommencer de prendre conscience de ce
que nous avons manqué non pas pour juger
ceux qui ont pu agir ou décider avant
nous mais pour pouvoir enfin nous
réconcilier avec la réalité et repartir
du concret repartir du terrain
reconstruire refonder rebâtir la crise
que nous traversons est une chance
inédite
parce qu'elle est l'occasion de revenir
au réel dans des périodes de fausses
prospérité on peut parfois se perdre
dans des abstractions et sans doute nous
avons sombré dans une forme de déni de
réalité sur tant de sujets qui touchent
à la ville notre pays sans doute la vie
politique s'est abîmé dans une sorte de
jeu d'ombrés d'artifice abstrait qui
nous ont éloignés ensemble des choix que
nous avions affaire est sans doute y at
il eu une forme de scandale
progressivement de plus en plus aiguës
dans la distance qui s'est créée entre
ce que nous savions devoir faire et ce
que nous faisions vraiment et bien la
crise dans laquelle nous sommes nous
contraint à l'exigence et nous obligent
à reconstruire et c'est une chance
oui nous avons toutes les raisons
d'espérer parce que nous le voyons
partout en france malgré toutes les
difficultés malgré l'obstacle que nous
ne cessons parfois de nous imposer à
nous mêmes
malgré le découragement qui pourraient
poindre il y attend d'énergie partout
tant de créativité tant de générosité
temps d'engagement dans cette entreprise
que nous visitions tout à leur temps de
performance d'excellence de savoir faire
oui bien sûr si nous savons nous libérer
des freins que nous nous imposons à nous
même si nous savons mettre fin à cette
crise qui est d'abord en nous et non pas
en dehors de nous alors oui c'est sûr
nous avons toutes les raisons de croire
que notre avenir peut être encore très
beau et que nous pouvons encore
longtemps
faire l'histoire nous avons
toutes les raisons d'y croire et ma
dernière raison d'espérer chez rémy et
bien c'est vous c'est le fait que vous
soyez là on vous explique depuis des
semaines que maintenant cette élection
européenne c'est l'occasion de voter
contre
monsieur macron vous dit que tout
l'enjeu de cette élection européenne
c'est de voter contre madame le pen et à
madame le pen vous dit que tout l'enjeu
de cette élection européenne c'est de
voter contre monsieur macron et ce
faisant d'ailleurs ils se font la
réponse l'un l'autre et ils se rendent
service l'un l'autre à la fin le vote
utile par quelques bords qu'on le
présente n'est toujours utile qu'à eux
deux qui continue ce numéro qui n'est
rien d'autre que l'occasion pour le pays
dans lequel nous sommes de s'abîmer
petit à petit dans un désespoir
politique car il n'y a pas d'alternative
dans cet éternel deuxième tour et vous
êtes là parce que vous avez décidé que
vous vouliez voté pour que vous ne
pouviez plus des élections triste que
vous n'en pouvez plus des élections par
défaut que vous voulez voter pour pour
l'europe que nous voulons pour la france
que nous aimons pour l'espoir dont nous
avons besoin
eh bien chers amis ce soir vous êtes le
signe de cet espoir parce que vous êtes
là parce que vous ne vous êtes pas
résigné parce que vous ne vous êtes pas
laisser aller au fatalisme
parce que vous ne voulez pas vous
laisser enfermer dans un vote par défaut
mais que vous voulez faire un vote
d'espoir votez pour vos convictions
vous êtes resté fidèle vous serez fidèle
jusqu'au bout et nous serons fidèles
ensemble il y as parmi nos laurent nous
nous en faisions la réflexion à
l'instant il y as parmi nous tant de
jeunes ce soir il y as parmi nous louise
et baptiste et je voudrais dire
d'ailleurs un immense merci à charlotte
pour tout ce qu'elle a porté aussi de
cette campagne
il y as parmi nos temps de ces visages
de jeunes qui sont là pour écrire
l'avenir et le même bernanos disait que
c'est cette fièvre de la jeunesse qui
maintient le monde à la bonne
température surtout chers jeunes qui est
ici
ne vous laissez pas refroidir nous ne
voulons pas nous laisser refroidir nous
ne voulons pas nous résigner
nous croyons qu'il est possible de
s'enthousiasmer encore pour l'avenir de
notre pays et pour l'avenir de l'europe
et nous sommes là ensemble ce soir pour
écrire cette histoire
vive la france et vive l'europe
[Applaudissements]